Last time I told you that Sumerian had
a massive influence on later today,
foreign languages. I spared you
the details though, until now.
Here's my favorite example of
Sumerian. Ization run a muck.
Okay.
Sumerian cuneiform built words
with two kinds of characters,
syllable characters, and these
kinds of picture word characters.
So scribes could write about a star
by drawing the word character star or
spelling it with the syllables. Mu
and Ooh, Moodle, Sumerian, four star.
When the Acadians took over cuneiform,
they grabbed that word symbol
and also syllables to write.
Cock kaaboo their own
Acadian word for star.
But the Acadians kept around
some Samarian baggage.
Actually a lot of Samarian baggage,
which led them to a bazaar. Third option,
spell the word in Samarian, but
pronounce it in Acadian. This technique,
let them transform Sumerian words
into new symbols. Simera grams,
Acadian words with Sumerian spellings.
The Hittites got sucked into this when
they joined the Akkadian Cuneiform party.
The native Hittite word for
backwards was up reasonably.
Hittite scribes wrote it
with three characters,
but they could also switch in
the Sumerian word for back.
Write it this way with the Sumeria ground.
It wasn't just Simera grounds though
the Hittites turn this around on the
Acadians creating a Qaeda
grounds. Here's a strange example.
Acadian used lots of little prepositions,
kind of like English on a meant for as an
Ana Lugo for the king.
No surprise king is in Samarian
there Hittite work differently.
It had all of these Indo
European case endings.
Therefore the king had a root hus Su and
an attached ending II date of case or
for like in Latin or Greek.
Oddly he type describes,
could write the Acadian preposition on
a next to the Sumerian Lugo even while
they read it as the Hittite Noun
with the case ending. What a mess.
Just imagine if English writers
glorified a language of this much.
It's like writing the word city in Greek,
but insisting that those characters spell
this sound city and then in a phrase
like for the city, we'll slap a Latin
case sending on to the Greek. Good gram.
Here's, see, this means
money for the city.
Obviously actually Somero Keto
grams are worse. At least Greek,
Latin and English are related. Hittite,
Acadian and Samarian are three
different beasts. Anyhow,
that's one very quirky example of the
kind of linguistic influence Sumerian
cuneiform had on later.
Civilizations stick around throughout
2015 from more about writing and
subscribed for language.
[inaudible].